SARA ROBINSON: Hi there.
In this video, I'll show
you some tips and tricks
to help you prepare your image
data in Cloud AutoML Vision.
Although I'll be showing
AutoML Vision here,
the concepts I'll be showing
apply to AutoML Natural
Language as well.
For this walkthrough,
we'll be building a model
to detect the type
of cloud in an image,
because there's no better
place to analyze clouds
than the Cloud.
I've got five possible
labels, each corresponding
with a different type of cloud.
There are many ways to add
labeled images to your AutoML
Vision data set.
In this video, I'll show
you how to do the following.
First, we'll upload
labeled images directly
from our computer.
Then, we'll review image labels
and add additional images
in the AutoML Vision UI.
The cloud images on my
computer are organized
into folders for each label.
Using this approach,
I can create
a zip file of these folders.
And when I upload
the zip to AutoML,
it will use the folder names
to automatically assign labels
to each image.
For example, this
image of a cirrus cloud
will get the cirrus
label assigned,
since it's in that folder.
I'll create the zip now.
I've already enabled AutoML
Vision for this project
and created my data set.
So next, let's upload the
zip file of labeled images.
Note that AutoML Vision has a
30 megabyte file size limit.
For larger data
sets, you can either
create multiple zip files,
or upload your images
to Google Cloud Storage
and create a labeled CSV.
With all of my labeled
images uploaded,
it's time to review them
in the AutoML Vision UI.
Here, I can look at all
of the images assigned
to a specific label to make
sure they're labeled correctly.
Looking at the cirrus images,
it seems like this one
is incorrectly labeled.
I can click on it and switch
it to the correct label,
cumulonimbus.
Since I created my label
data set, some of my friends
heard about this
project and sent
over a few of their own cloud
images to be used in training.
Let's add them.
From the All Images tab, I can
select Add Images, and then
Upload From Your Computer.
Notice that because I uploaded
these from the All Images tab,
they went into the
Unlabeled category.
I can click on Unlabelled
to go in and add labels
to these images.
One of my friends
is a cloud expert
and sent me images
specifically of cirrus clouds.
I can apply that label to them
directly by clicking on Cirrus,
and then adding the images.
Now that I've got all
of my images uploaded,
let's explore what I can do
with the image selection tool.
I can click the check mark here
to select all images on a page,
or I can select
individual images
by clicking on the checkbox
on the top left of an image.
With images selected, I can move
them to the Unlabeled category
by clicking on Label,
and then Unlabel.
These images will
still be in my data
set and will remain
in Cloud storage,
but because they
don't have a label,
they won't be used in training.
To delete an image from
my data set entirely
and from Google Cloud Storage,
I can select it, and then
press Delete.
There are also some handy label
ordering tools on the left.
If I click on the
menu bar here, I
can choose how I want
to order my labels.
I can order them
alphabetically, or if I
want to see where I
need to add more images,
I can sort from fewest to most.
Remember that you need at
least 10 images per label
to train a model
in AutoML Vision.
To start gathering images
of a new cloud type,
I can add the label here and
start importing images for it.
Now that I've
uploaded all my images
and labeled them
correctly, I can
export the data set to a
cloud storage directory.
This will create a
CSV file with details
on whether an image was
included in the training, test,
or validation data set, its
Google Cloud Storage URL,
and its corresponding label.
This is useful if I want to
share the data set with others
on my team, or see
how my data set was
split for training and testing.
With all my images
uploaded and labeled,
I'm ready to train my model.
The great thing about
AutoML is that I
don't need to
worry about writing
any of the code for my model.
All I need to do is click
a button to train it.
That's all for now.
Stay tuned for future videos
to cover more AutoML features.